[Music]  [Music]  sir  remember the moving spike we spotted in  the infection rate  oops  [Music]  sorry about that  what have you got kid well i  cross-correlated the data with worldwide  ir codes and it changes things quite  significantly it's impossible for a  strain to spread that fast crossing  borders at the speed of light  crisscrossing the globe in 24 hours  but when did you get those preposterous  figures uh  christmas eve  looks like you've got your clearance to  engage  the well has moved on  magic dust pieces of coal it's time for  something a little more reliable  do you have any idea what you've done  you've led them right to it  i didn't think any of this was great and  now they won't stop until it's all gone  [Music]  don't be honest  [Music]  you